used to fire him
this is
about when the president finally agreed
to turn over nine of the
tapes of the conversations that were
under subpoena
and it gives you a sense of what
the look and feel
of the country was
during this period and it's 17 minutes
long and we'll be back to
hear more of your thoughts and to hear
from john fionka
good evening the biggest white house
scandal in a century the watergate
scandal broke wide open today the
attorney general richard kleindienst has
resigned because in his own words he had
close personal and professional
associations with people who may have
broken the law the two closest men to
the president h.r haldeman his chief of
staff and john ehrlichman his chief
domestic advisor have resigned last week
both men were fighting hard to keep
their jobs the president's white house
legal counsel john dean has been fired
reportedly dean is implicated in efforts
to cover up the watergate scandal and he
may implicate erlichman and haldeman the
secretary of defense eliot richardson
will be nominated as attorney general
leonard garment of the white house will
fill in for john dean all this in a
presidential statement read by press
secretary ron ziegler
the president has asked me to announce
that he has today received and accepted
the resignation of richard kleindings as
attorney general of the united states he
is appointing elliot richardson to
succeed mr kleinding's as attorney
general
and will submit mr richardson's name to
the senate for confirmation immediately
president nixon has also asked me to
announce that he is today accepting the
resignation of two of his closest
friends and most trusted assistants in
the white house
h.r haldeman and john ehrlichman
the president told them he knew their
decision to resign was difficult
and that his decision to accept it was
also difficult
but he also said that he respects and
appreciates the attitude that led them
to it
the president wishes to emphasize that
neither the submission
nor the acceptance of mr holdemans and
mr ehrlichman's resignation at this time
should be seen by anyone as evidence of
any wrongdoing by either one
such assumptions would be both unfair
and unfounded
i've also been asked to announce that
the president has today requested and
accepted the resignation of john dean
from his position
of the white house council
the white house is in a state of shock
and a lot of people here are wondering
how many more heads are going to roll
for the time being the nerve center of
the government has gone virtually dead
while there's no word yet on
replacements for haldeman or erlichmann
there's a general feeling the vaunted
white house staff structure itself will
now be revamped so as to provide greater
access to the president
there's no word either on a new
secretary of defense but some officials
are saying privately the administration
may now have difficulty in recruiting
good people to work for it
the president himself worked in solitude
throughout the day at his camp david
retreat preparing his speech
he spent the weekend at camp david
talking to most of the people involved
in today's announcements
haldeman ehrlichman kleindings
richardson garment but not dean
he also discussed his problems at length
with a man he has frequently turned to
during past crises secretary of state
william rogers
tonight the president is expected to
explain to the nation how he reached his
drastic decision and why
richard valeriani nbc news at the white
house
both haldeman and ehrlichman say they
will voluntarily cooperate with the
watergate grand jury in the special
senate investigations although there
have been reports that they would have
been asked to do that in any case
and president nixon says he's given
elliott richardson the job of
recommending changes in the law so that
to use the president's words future
campaign abuses of the sort recently
uncovered may be prevented
ehrlichman in an interview with nbc news
said tonight that there has been too
much innuendo and rumor flying around
about watergate he said also that he and
haldeman have become symbols in the
scandal erlichman said again he is
innocent of any wrongdoing tonight at
nine o'clock eastern time president
nixon goes on television and radio to
talk to the country about watergate
the president's drastic shake-up at the
white house pleased almost every member
of congress for various reasons many
senior republicans have been urging the
president to clean house and he has now
acknowledged that pressure another
reason is that of all the two and a half
million people in the executive branch
by far the most unpopular were h.r
haldeman and john erlickman unpopular
with republicans and democrats alike
paul duke was on the hill when those
resignations were announced
one republican senator said the news was
enough to cause dancing in the halls of
congress the remark illustrated the deep
dislike of haldeman and ehrlichman long
regarded as arrogant and contemptuous
toward members of congress because the
two aides demanded unswerving loyalty to
the president republicans found it
difficult getting to mr nixon if they
deviated even slightly from white house
policy the result was bad feeling and
bad relations for mr nixon thus there
were no tears for messrs haldeman and
erlickman i don't think they like people
i think
i think that
they just give the attitude that
they didn't like people my impression of
hollerman very shortly after he was in
there and ehrlichman i think
particularly mr earlman very soon after
he was in there i happened to i'd met
him at receptions i haven't run into him
at the airport with his family he's
evidently putting him on a plane for
somebody
i went up and spoke to him
well
i never got such a cool off in my life
i'm sure he knew who i was but this is
typical of the uh
of the whole thing i don't really
believe that they
told the president everything
uh
and i assume they saw themselves getting
in hot water they're even less inclined
to tell the president anything some
thought it would blow away some thought
it would go away
the result was that it didn't the result
beyond that is that it's uh
not a disaster the republican party but
it certainly stained the political
system and all of us involved in it
the attempt to intimidate the members of
the congress is the same as the attempt
to intimidate the members of the press
and great newspapers and television and
radio networks and so forth the media
has been subjected to the same process
that we have the same arrogance they
have been the recipient of
and why this was not apparent before i
do not know but i am very pleased that
the president has now acted as
precipitously
as thoroughly as he now has and i hope
every last person
that was involved in this case will be
dismissed from the federal government
watergate has added to mr nixon's
difficulties on capitol hill but with
haldeman and erlichmann gone white house
relations with congress may well improve
once the scandal is over
paul duke nbc news at the capitol
fred briggs went out to a republican
suburb of chicago today a suburb which
has always voted for richard nixon
briggs talked to people trying to find
out how they felt about today's white
house announcement and here is his
report
wilmette is a high income north shore
suburb of chicago it has a long
republican tradition and it held to that
last november by re-electing richard
nixon by a better than two to one margin
over george mcgovern
we talked today is asking the security
director of the 1972 committee to
re-elect the president which has been
called creep his name is james mccord
about g gordon liddy's political
espionage operation and the amount of
money involved and a meeting in the
attorney general's office then attorney
general john mitchell it's about four
minutes and we'll get
your reaction to it and also mr lewis
want to have your reaction
mr lady
come to you after each important meeting
or after each meeting where these
matters were discussed
and give you a summary of the meeting
and what was discussed and what the
conclusions were not after each meeting
at all
but
we would see each other regularly during
the week i'd say if not once a day at
least every other day most weeks between
january and june 17th
sometimes he would tell me i'm getting
ready to go up to see the attorney
general to discuss this operation
referring to the watergate operation
to discuss the operations that he had
planned
sometimes he would tell me i've just
come back from that operation and here's
what
we're going to do now some of these for
some of these meetings according to him
according to what he told you
while mr mitchell was still attorney
general
yes
and some after he came to the committed
re-election yes
were money figures discussed oh yes what
he said what was the according to mr
lady what was the original
uh proposed budget for the for the
overall surveillance operation i assume
we are talking about the overall
operation and not just the watergate uh
un is that correct talking about
three categories political espionage
photography operations and the
electronic operations and the original
figure
in february that mr liddy proposed
as i saw in writing
in a draft on his desk at one occasion
and in a typed memorandum on a second
occasion was approximately four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
all right was according to him was that
uh budget approved
[Music]
the sequence
of the events
were that
there were planning meetings
in january or february
are both
in the attorney general's offices
in which mr dean and mr magruder mr
liddy
and mr mitchell discussed
the original amount the 450 000
amount and subsequently
approximately thirty days after the
first quote formal meeting that i heard
referred to by mr liddy
there was a figure of approximately two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars which
he said had been approved
for the operation and he referred also
to some additional funds which he had
in the order of
approximately a hundred thousand dollars
so that figure is not absolutely certain
in my mind which would total about
something around three hundred thousand
dollars three hundred fifty thousand
dollars according to him
was this was this money problem the
the
need for subsequent meetings
was that a concern of the people
involved was there quite a bit of
discussion as to exactly how much money
should be spent on this project
money was a topic
that he said was discussed
he said the
individual operations were discussed
that is
specifically the three parts of his
budget
which he had prepared on charts which he
had taken to at least one of the
meetings
that is the three parts of political
espionage and photography and so on it
was not limited the discussion was not
limited to the matter of funding my
understanding was all aspects
of the operations were discussed in
those meetings by the four individuals
let me just ask you this did he tell you
that john that uh john mitchell ever
told him that this budget is just too
high and you'll have to do it for less
or something no to that extent no is it
fun
did he ever tell you that uh they
specifically discussed the watergate
operation in any any of these uh
meetings
which meetings are you referring to i'm
talking about any meetings which he had
with the attorney general when any of
these other people were present oh yes
the watergate break-in specifically was
discussed very definitely
charles lewis of the center for public
integrity what do you think after seeing
that clip
well it brings back memories
informations in the book and we hope
that you will help us
spread it across the country thank you
you're looking at a picture of the
watergate hotel
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
the watergate break-in
and thursday we continue a week-long
look at the events that led to the
resignation of president nixon
we'll also show you some archival
footage of the senate watergate hearings
including this portion as james mccord
testified before the senate watergate
committee in may 1973
he was the security director of the 1972
committee to reelect the president
[Applause]
when did you first know
john or jack
caulfield
i first met him in early
19
early september 1971
i had heard of him before where was he
working the time you first met him at
the white house
did he have any connection later with
rather i believe you stated that uh you
were employed by the committee to
reelect
the president on the recommendation of
mr caulfield yes sir
did mr caulfield later have any
association with the committee
yes sir
and after that association
did he go to one of the executive
departments
i understood from him that is the
adjustment you know which department
i believe it was the treasury department
and you know what is what position he
held there
it was a senior position with the
i believe it's called the alcohol tax
and firearms division
now was he working in the treasury
department at the time that he had the
meetings with you he told me that
yesterday yes
as i recall
you met with him first
on friday january the 12th
somewhere on the george washington
parkway
it was that friday yesterday did he give
you any reason why he wanted to meet you
on a george washington parkway instead
of seeing that you you at his home or
your home no sir
uh who was president that meeting
just the two of us
and um
at that time he urged you to plead the
guilty
the case was still pinned and was not
yes just about the time the trial
started wasn't it this was the first
week of the trial
and he urged you to plead guilty and
assured you that if you are
pleaded guilty you would receive
executive clemency and also be are given
a chance
after you served innocence to help to be
rehabilitated and job didn't it
i believe all is correct except the word
plead guilty and i'll try to restate
that for accuracy the word plead guilty
had been used over the telephone to me
by this unknown unidentified individual
whose voice i described and that was
subsequently that was prior to the
meetings yes sir yes now then uh
excuse me
do you have something further
well in the conversations on the 12th of
january and in the two subsequent
meetings
the word plead guilty
would come up in this general language
are you going to plead guilty
or how about pleading guilty
what's your feelings on pleading now
now this meeting was raised and his
instance wasn't yes sir
then you met him again on sunday january
the 14th uh on the george washington
parkway yes
and what was your conversation with him
that time was rather was that meeting
hell at his instance yes sir
oh what occurred at that time
i may refer to my notes to be sure
the discussion was
[Music]
that there was no objection to renewing
the motion on discovery of government
wiretapping and that if that failed i
would receive executive clemency after
10 to 11 months
and then the conversation went on to say
that quote the president's ability to
govern is at stake
another teapot dome scandal is possible
and the government may fall
everybody else is on track but you you
are not following the game plan get
closer to your attorney
you see
that conversation occur in automobile or
did you get out of the automobile well
sir it was out of an automobile and it
was about
50 feet i would guess from his car
where we walked
down towards the potomac river from the
overlook just the two of us were present
and tomorrow night our watergate series
continues with a discussion about
watergate's effect on news reporting
participants include richard cohen and
walter pincus of the washington post
ron ostrow of the los angeles times and
john fialca of the wall street journal
later mr fiacco will be joining us live
in the studio to take your phone calls
watergate's 25th anniversary thursday on
c-span at 8 p.m eastern 5 pacific
and on saturday night we'll look back at
president nixon's white house farewell
from 1974.
you can see the archival video at 8 30
eastern end pacific
this year marks the centennial
anniversary of the library of congress's
jefferson building last week
that council john dean is talking about
whether the anti-nixon demonstrations
were being orchestrated orchestrated by
the democrats i'd like to get your
reaction to this when it's done this is
john dean from 1973.
i stated earlier that there was a
continuing dissatisfaction with the
available intelligence reports
the most frequent critic was mr holloman
but the president himself discussed this
with me in early march of this year as a
part of the plan counter-offensive for
dealing with the senate watergate
investigation
the president wanted to show that his
opponents had employed demonstrators
against him during his reelection
campaign
however with each demonstration that the
president was confronted with and each
incident that occurred during the
campaign
my office had sought to determine
if it had in fact been instigated by
political opponents of the president
senator mcgovern the democratic party or
whoever
we never found a centilla of viable
evidence indicating that these
demonstrators were part of the master
plan nor that they were funded by
democratic political funds nor they had
any direct connection with the mcgovern
campaign
this was explained to mr holloman but
the president believed that the opposite
was in fact true
i have submitted to the committee
exhibit number one
the text of the president's memorandum
to me on this subject
on on february 16 1973
almost a month prior
to this direct request from the
president
i had at mr holloman's request
received all the available intelligence
on the demonstrations the president had
been subjected to during the 1972
campaign
this intelligence did not evidence what
the president was looking for but i
turned it over to mr william baruti
telling him that the president wanted a
speech as part of a counter-offensive to
the watergate inquiry
len garman your reaction
well i don't know really it's something
that uh deponent knoweth not i mean i i
don't know uh who
whether those organizations during the
white house during the watergate era
joining us to take your calls from
california but by way of introduction we
want to show you a little bit of his
first day
on the
witness stand before the senate
watergate committee in july of 1975 this
is john dean
with portions of his opening statement
mr dean
do you have a statement you wish to
present to the committee that's correct
mr dash but
before i commence reading the rather
lengthy statement uh i would just like
to
make a couple comments
first of all mr chairman mr vice
chairman and member of the committee i
i sincerely wish i could say it's my
pleasure to be here today but i think
you can understand why it's not steen
could you please take the microphone and
put it closer to you
certainly
it's a very difficult thing for me
to testify about other people it's far
more easy for me to explain my own
involvement in this matter
the fact that i was involved in
obstruction of justice the fact that i
assisted
another in
perjured testimony
the fact that i
made personal use of funds that were in
my custody
it's far easier to talk about these
things myself than to talk about what
others did
some of these people i'll be referring
to are friends
some are men i greatly admire and
respect
and particularly with reference to the
president united states i'd like to say
this
it is my honest belief
while the president was involved
that he did not realize or appreciate
at any time the implications of his
involvement
and i think that when the facts come out
i hope the president is forgiven
pursuant to the request of the committee
i will commence with a general
description
of the atmosphere that existed in the
white house
prior to june
1972
to one who was in the white house and
became somewhat familiar with its inner
workings
the watergate matter was an inevitable
outgrowth of a climate of excessive
concern
over the political impact of
demonstrators
excessive concern over leaks
an insatiable appetite for political
intelligence
all coupled with a do-it-yourself white
house staff
regardless of the law
however
the fact that many of these elements
this climate culminated with the
creation
of a covert intelligence operation as
part of the president's re-election
committee
was not by conscious design
rather an accident of fate
these of course are my conclusions but i
believe they are well founded in fact
this committee however is not interested
in my conclusions
rather interested in the facts as i know
them
rather than my characterizing the
climate and attitudes i shall as
requested
present the facts which themselves
evidence
some of the precursors of the watergate
incident it was when i joined the white
house staff in july of 1970 that i
became fully aware of the extent of
concern at the white house regarding
demonstrations and intelligence
information relating to demonstrators
it was approximately one month after i
arrived
at the white house that i was informed
about a project that had been going on
before i arrived to restructure the
government's intelligence gathering
capacities vis-a-vis demonstrators and
domestic radicals
the revised domestic intelligence plan
was submitted in a document form to the
president for his approval
the president of the committee has in
its possession a copy of that document
in certain related memoranda
pursuant to the order of judge sarika
after i was told of the presidentially
approved plan
they called for bugging
burglarizing
mail covers and the like i was
instructed by mr holloman
to see what i could do to get the plan
implemented
i thought the plan was totally uncalled
for and unjustified
i talked with mr mitchell about the plan
he said he knew there was great con
concern or desire at the white house to
see that the plan was implemented but he
agreed fully with fbi director hoover
who opposed the plan
with one exception
mitchell thought that an interagency
evaluation committee might be useful
because
it was not good to have the fbi standing
alone without the information of other
intelligence agencies and the sharing of
information is always good and avoids
duplication
after my conversation with mitchell i
wrote a memorandum requesting that the
evaluation committee be established
and the restraints could be removed
later
i told mr holloman
that the only way to proceed was one
step at a time
and this could be an important first
step
he agreed
john dean that was 24 years ago what are
your thoughts today about those first
hours that you were on that witness
stand well i was just reflecting on it
uh it was a very muggings buggings and
prostitutes and kidnapping to disarm
political opponents and it's about six
and a half minutes long and we'd
certainly like to have your reflection
on that after we finish it and of course
uh to hear from our audience
so after that the next time i recall
meeting liddy
was at a medium mitchell's office
in january 27 1972
magruder called my office
to set up the meeting and only after i
called maguire to ask why he wanted me
to attend the meeting did i learn that
he was going to present his intelligence
plan
i met magruder and liddy at mitchell's
office
that he had a series of charts
or diagrams which he placed on an easel
and the presentation valet began
i did not fully understand everything
mr liddy was recommending at that time
because some of the concepts were
mind-boggling and the charts were in
code names but i shall attempt to
reconstruct the high points that i
remember as best i can
libby was in effect making a sales pitch
he said that the operation he had
developed would be totally removed from
the campaign
and carried out by professionals
fans called for muggy squads kidnapping
teams
prosecutors to compromise the opposition
and electronic service
he explained that the mugging squad
could for example rough up demonstrators
that were causing problems
the kidnapping teams could remove
demonstration leaders and take them
below the mexican border and thereby
diminish their ability
the ability of the demonstrators to
cause problems at the san diego
convention
the prostitutes could be used at the
democratic convention to get information
as well as compromised persons involved
i recall that he's saying that the girls
would be high class and the best in the
business
when discussing the electronic
surveillance he said that he had
consulted with one of the best
authorities in the country and his plan
envisioned far more than bugging and
tapping of telephones
he said that under his plan
communications between ground facilities
and aircraft
could also be intercepted
might also at this point he also gave an
elaborate description of intercepting
various microwaves that traveled around
the country through various uh
communication facilities and i cannot
explain to the committee what that was
because to this day i don't understand
it
each major aspect
of his proposal was on a chart
with one chart showing the
interrelations with the others
each operation was given a code name i
have no recollection of these code names
with regard to surveillance
i did not recall if this was necessarily
limited to electronic surveillance
he suggested several potential targets
i cannot recall for certain if it was
during this meeting or a second meeting
in early february that he suggested the
potential targets the targets that i
recall
he suggested were mr larry o'brien the
democratic headquarters and the fountain
blue hotel during the democratic
convention
mr liddy concluded his presentation by
saying that the plan would cost
approximately one million dollars
i do not recall magruder's reaction
during the presentation of the plan
because he was seated beside me
but i do recall mitchell's reaction to
the mission impossible plan he was
amazed at one point i gave him a look of
a bewilderment and he winked
knowing mitchell
i did not think they would throw liddy
out of the office
or tell him that he was out of his mind
rather he did what i expected when the
presentation was completed he took a few
long puffs on his pipe
and told liddy that the plan he
developed was not quite what he had in
mind and the cost was out of the
question
he said he suggested that he go back and
revise his plan
keeping in mind
he was most interested
in the demonstration problem
i remained in mitchell's office for a
brief moment after the meeting ended
as the charts were being
taken off the easel and disassembled
and mitchell indicated to me that mr
liddy's proposal was out of the question
i then joined magruder and liddy
and as we left the office i told lydia
to destroy the charts
mr letty said that he would revise the
plan and submit a new proposal
at that point i thought the plan was
dead
because i doubted if mitchell would
reconsider the matter i wrote back to
the to my office with lydia and magruder
but there was no further discussion of
the plan
the next time i became aware of any
discussions of such plans occurred i
believe on february 4th 1972
excuse me magruder had scheduled another
meeting in mr mitchell's office on a
revised intelligence plan i arrived at
the meeting very late and when i came in
lydia was presenting a scaled-down
version of his earlier plan
i listened for a few minutes and decided
i had to inject myself into the
discussions
mr mitchell i felt was being put on the
spot
the only polite way i thought i could
end the discussion was to inject that
these discussions could not go on in the
office of the attorney general of the
united states and the meeting should
terminate immediately
at this point the meeting ended
i do not know
to this day who kept pushing for these
plans whether he was pushing or whether
magruder was pushing whether someone was
pushing magruder i do not know
i do know in hindsight
that i should not have been as polite as
i was in merely suggesting that lydia
destroy the charge
rather i should have said forget the
plan completely
after i ended the second meeting i told
liddy that i would never again discuss
this matter with him
i told him that if any such plan were
approved
i did not want to know
one thing was certain in my mind while
someone wanted this operation i did not
want any part of it nor would i have any
part of it
after this second meeting in mitchell's
office i sought a meeting with mr
halliman to tell him what was occurring
but it took me several days to get to
see him
i recall that mr higby got me into
mister hall in his office when another
appointment had been cancelled or
postponed
i told holliman what had been presented
by liddy and told him that i felt it was
incredible unnecessary and unwise
i told him that no one in the white
house should have anything to do with
this
i said that
the re-election committee will
need an ability to deal with
demonstrations
but it did not need
bugging mugging prostitutes and
kidnappers
pauloman agreed and told me
that i should have no further dealings
on the matter
you know i know he felt good
next week at this time we'll hear more
from alexander butterfield in the second
part of this oral history interview
recorded for the richard nixon
presidential library this is the 40th
anniversary of butterfield's testimony
to the senate watergate committee in
which he revealed the existence of the
white house secret taping system here's
a short clip of his appearance as he's
questioned by minority council fred
thompson who later served as u.s senator
from tennessee
so you were employed on january 21st
1969 and continue to be employed until
march 14 of this year is that correct
that's correct mr butterfield are you
aware of the installation of any
listening devices in the oval office of
the president
i was aware of
listening devices
yes sir when were those devices placed
in the oval office
approximately
the summer of 1970 i cannot
begin to recall the precise date my
guess
mr thompson is that the installation was
made
between
and this is a very rough guess
april
or may
of 1970 and perhaps the end of the
summer or early fall 1970.
are you aware of any devices that were
installed in the executive office
building office of the president
yes sir at that time were they installed
at the same time
they were installed at the same time
could you tell us a little bit about how
those devices worked
how they were activated for example
i don't have the technical knowledge but
i will
tell you what i know about
how those devices were triggered
they were installed of course
for historical purposes to record
the president's business and they were
installed in his two offices the oval
office and the eob office
you're watching american history tv
all weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
for more information channel you can
check it throughout the day for updated
c-span schedule information
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
the watergate break-in and this week
c-span airs a series of panel
discussions with key figures from the
watergate era here's a brief look at
some of tonight's program
since he had indicated to you that a
public
effort might be misinterpreted that he
stressed that this had to be completely
secret yes he made a very strong
point that there was absolute secrecy
required
confidentiality
indicating that if this became known
that it would might jeopardize the
campaign and would
because of misinterpretation
as to the reasons for raising these
funds and for the help of these people
now have you ever been given any other
assignments of this nature in the past
no sir
after meeting with mr dean uh what did
you do did you did you indicate first
that you would accept this assignment
for mr dean i did
and this uh and you did accept it under
the on the basis that if mr dean was
asking you
as the president's counsel that he had
authority to ask you for that absolutely
i had known mr dean
since mid 1970 and i had
complete trust in the man
and knowing that he was the
counsel to the president
all right then you accepted this
assignment what did you do right after
that meeting with mr dean
i walked back to the statler hilton
and
i think within a matter of minutes after
i was back at the hotel i called mr
stanz
and what did you say to mr stan i told
him that i had been given a special
assignment
requiring
as much cash as
perhaps he would have available i think
i mentioned 50 to 100 000
and uh asked him if it would be possible
that he could help me in this assignment
and what did he say
he said that he would
see what he could do
he said that he would have as i
remembered he said he would have to go
to a safe deposit box
but that he would meet me at at the
statler hilton in my room
uh early in the afternoon and did he
meet you early in the afternoon yes sir
he did and did he have anything with him
yes he did he had he gave me five
thousand one hundred dollars
um how were they packaged it was in one
hundred dollar bills as i remember i'm
waiting and did he indicate to you the
source of that money yeah mr combat he
did as to forty five thousand he said
that it was the balance
of the fifty that he had earlier given
me
he said that uh he
he was given into to me now but he did
not indicate as i remember it all at all
the source of the balance of those funds
tonight we continue our look at the
events leading up to president nixon's
resignation and the long form the
plumbers of course being the break-in
team headed by gordon liddy and howard
hunt that broke into not only the
watergate
but into the office of daniel ellsberg's
psychiatrist that wiretapped reporters
wiretapped members of the white house
staff
that
staged sabotage operations uh at the
democratic convention
and engaged in other undercover and
illegal activities against nixon's
political opponents and that unit is the
subject of this exchange between sam
dash and john erlickman from july of
1973 it's about four minutes we'll be
back to take more of your calls with
carl bernstein
did you were you assigned a role
to create in the white house a
capability for intelligence gathering at
any time
i don't know quite uh what you're
getting at if you're getting at the
special unit and the and the problems of
leaks i don't know why you have to find
out what i'm getting at if you just
answer my question as i ask it's a it's
an obscure question too no it's a simple
question if the answer is no say no if
the answer is yes say yes
would you would you restate the question
for me please i said did there come a
time when you were asked to develop a
capability in the white house
for intelligence gathering intelligence
gathering the answer would be no
all right
now
you were trying to seek what i was
getting at did you ever
were you ever asked to set up a special
unit in the white house for the purpose
of determining whether certain leaks
that occurred in major national security
areas
in point of fact i was and i'm strictly
in terms of your question i was not
asked to set it up
uh
mr krogh was asked to set it up
now who is mr crow but bud kroger eagle
croak jr uh was a member of the domestic
council staff and
[Music]
he was asked by the president to form
this special unit
i was designated as as
one to whom mr krogh
could come with problems in connection
with it and the president said also that
he could come to him oh were you in at
the beginning of the setting up of this
yes i was and you knew what the unit was
to do yes all right what was the unit to
do
the unit as originally conceived
was to stimulate the various departments
and agencies
to do a better job of controlling
uh leaks and
the
theft or or other exposure of national
security secrets from within their
departments
it was a group which was to
bring to account so to speak
the various security
offices of the departments of defense
and state and justice and cia to get
them to do a better job
and
therefore this unit
was to gather facts
if there was a leak or to act as a turn
i take it to prevent leaks
no
no
there would have been no need to gather
facts under that under that concept
except to know that there had been an
occurrence
but to
require
vigorous
and uh very active effort on the part of
the responsible people in the
departments and agencies to find out
who was responsible and how it happened
and make sure it couldn't happen again
now isn't that getting getting facts if
you were seeking to find out who was
responsible
and you
and the unit was looking for it would
you be wanting to get facts well see you
were asking me about intelligence and
and uh jumping again ahead of me i
didn't say intelligence i said facts all
right the facts in that sense but but
limited to that now would you say some
people who go for uh seek facts in an
investigative way
can also say they seek intelligence well
but you see what i'm trying to say to
you is as originally set up and
conceived this was not an investigative
unit in the sense that your question
implies it was it was far more a group
that was established for the purpose of
getting
the security people in the departments
and agencies to do a better job of their
job did it ever was it ever called or
was that referred to as a an
investigative unit subsequently it was
because it became an investigative unit
subsequently
carl bernstein what do you make of john
ehrlichman's description of my best
opinion as to what it was but i couldn't
figure it out
our guest john dean will be with us till
the top of the hour right now though mr
dean we want to show you and everybody
else a piece of video from july of 73
and this time
it's at the watergate hearings on the
senate side and uh the president's
domestic advisor john ehrlichman
is testifying essentially that you were
wrong it's about a minute and three
quarters and we'd like to have your and
our audience's reaction to that
i had heavy duties and a rather specific
area of concern
i was not a generalist once i ceased
being counsel to the president in 1970
nor was i anyone siamese twin during
those years
listening to the star witness here
hyphenate me for five days i began to
know a little how a caboose feels
i began to know mr dean repeatedly and
facility would testify
and and he would say and so i informed
haldeman hyphen and hyphen erlichman of
so-and-so as if that were possible to do
with one phone call or drop by
it could not really happen
and in virtually every case to which he
referred in testimony it did not happen
and how much time did i actually spend
with mr dean learning about the break-in
or keeping abreast of developments to
assist ron ziegler on the issues or with
mr dean on any other subject for that
matter in the weeks following watergate
dean and i invariably met either in my
office or much more rarely in mr
holloman's with the exception of just
three or four meetings most of which
were held out of town
the logs for these two offices mr
haldeman's and mine demonstrate clearly
the frequency of my meetings with mr
dean
remember
pardon me
remember
dean testified that keeping watergate
covered up was a tremendous drain of my
time
and told all of the of all the
conferences and meetings i was having
with him about
let's be clear
i did not cover up anything to do with
watergate
it's john earthling and by the way we
want to uh practice bruce
with that background this is the
exchange between senator howard baker
and h.r haldeman in july of 1973.
the one thing that keeps recurring to me
and the one thing i've tried to put to
every witness that has unique
information in addition to their own
personal information and knowledge is
what did the president know and when did
he first know it
you were closer to the president united
states more often than probably any
other person in the world outside his
immediate family
i want to know what you can tell me in
that respect what did the president know
and when did he know it
i've tried to tell that in the
recounting of my statement but what the
president knew
about
the watergate
and if again if we can divide to pre
june 17 and post june 17
what he knew
was basically what has
been clearly established here there
doesn't seem to be much contention about
what he knew and when
on the pre-june 17 activities as i
see it he
knew through the
normal channels that the event had
occurred
he knew as
ongoing
developments in the in the course of the
investigation and prosecution took place
uh that uh specific individuals were
charged
tried and convicted
he was informed
and acted on the basis of the
information given him
that
the information
that was was made known was the complete
information
he was told as i think has been
recounted here uh several times the only
one in which i believe i was present was
uh
an occasion which uh perhaps the vice
chairman was
also present which was a breakfast of
the cabinet
and the
some of the republican leadership
in the congress
and the senior members of the white
house staff
in
september i believe on september 12
of 1972.
just for the record i was in tennessee
campaigning for my political survival at
that time all right sir
uh a number of your colleagues were
present at that that breakfast meeting
and the purpose of it was to review the
uh upcoming campaign a number of these
people were going to be out campaigning
for the president so on and and the
course of the meeting covered campaign
issues
and uh
questions and answers on various things
that the speakers want to know in the
process of that
the attorney general of the united
states spoke on the subject of the
watergate and reported to this group
that the facts of the investigation of
the watergate including the statistics
of numbers of interviews and and uh
all the facts that have been gathered
and so forth and then reported to this
group and the president as he had
reported earlier that uh the indictments
would be brought down in the next few
days
and that they uh would
complete the investigation the
investigation had been completed
and that uh
there it was clear to him and to the to
the
investigators and prosecutors that
that uh the guilt for the commission of
the crimes at the democratic national
committee
was limited to those people who would be
indicted
that it did not
rise further in the membership of the
staff of the committee to reelect the
president or the white house let me pick
up one or two stitches and by the way
let me say for the record that there's a
vote in progress which i've now already
missed there's nobody else in the
committee here and i'm going to continue
past my 10 minutes and yield a
commensurate amount of time out of my
next round to equalize things but
let me continue in this way rather than
put a rather rhetorical question which i
did what did the president know and what
do you know it which alliterates pretty
well but doesn't elicit much information
sometimes let me ask you two or three
things that
are of interest to me
what did the president say to you
when he found out that lydia
and mccord two officials of the crp and
important officials were caught in the
watergate or in connection with the
watergate situation
can you tell us that
no he expressed
at any time that you got
the the discussion turned to the the
question of the break-in at the
democratic committee just utter
incomprehension as to how such a thing
could have happened and why such a thing
would have happened have you ever asked
to talk to mccord or to liddy
no i don't believe so was it ever
discussed not
not to my knowledge anyone ever suggest
it to him i don't believe so did you
ever talk to mccord or liddy no sir
i see senator and always return now and
i'm past my time if i may i'll ask one
more question before i yield him
you know this tape situation has gotten
to be uh pretty celebrated affair yes
sir i understand that and you understand
that i made the motion to
institute litigation to test the
privilege of the president to withhold
that information from us
and i feel very strongly about that
subject
as i've indicated earlier i think my
concern in that respect is heightened by
your testimony and your reference to
portions of that tape
i also remarked parenthetically to mr
wilson that i gazed deep into his eyes
and couldn't divine quite what was going
on and i still can't and i'm going to
continue to tantalize him with that a
little but
what i want to point out to you is that
one statement in your addendum seems to
me to be of extraordinary importance and
i want to test the accuracy of your
recollection and the quality of your
note-taking from those tapes
i'm referring to the last to the next to
the last now the third and the last
sentence on page two the president said
there is no problem in raising a million
dollars
we can do that but it would be wrong
now if the period were to follow after
we can do that it would be a most
damning statement
if in fact the tapes clearly show he
said but it would be wrong it's an
entirely different context now how sure
are you mr alderman that those tapes and
facts say that
i'm absolutely positive that the tape do
you hear it with your own voice yeah
with my own ears yes i mean with your
own ears was there any distortion in the
quality of the tape in that respect
no i don't believe so
mr holdem and my final question is a
follow on from that
do you have any idea whether or not
other witnesses who were present at
other presidential conversations that
relate to the mandate of this committee
to inquire might also be entitled to
hear those tapes as they relate to their
conversations in order to refresh their
recollection
i don't know senator but i
uh it is my understanding that uh no one
would
first place almost
i don't think anybody that's uh that has
a period or will appear
uh before this committee uh knew of the
existence of the tapes what about john
dean he knows now we know the idea that
mr dean would be permitted to go to the
white house and listen to those tapes
no sir it's my understanding that that
uh no one has been or will be is the
rationale
for your utilization of them that it's
an aid to the refreshing of your
recollection for reporting to the
president as a former staff member
yes wouldn't that precisely exact same
situation apply to john dean not at this
point in time no
would you be agreeable mr alderman if it
could be negotiated otherwise would you
be agreeable personally as far as you're
concerned would you be agreeable to
bringing those tapes up here those two
tapes and playing them
senator you're asking me to take a
position
on a legal issue uh contrary to the
position that the white house is
perfectly free to confer with your
counsel if you wish i'm not asking will
you ask the president to do it
i'm not asking if you think we violate
the doctrine of separation of powers
i'm simply saying would bob haldeman a
witness before this committee be
agreeable as an individual if we can
otherwise procure the tapes
to them being brought here and being
played in public
having been advised by council that in
their opinion i'm not creating a legal
problem by uh
the answer that i would give
and that i would want to give without
even talking to council is that i would
welcome
that opportunity
because uh they would confirm what i've
told you
thank you
that's 24 years ago this month
washington dc we're back in the present
with leonard garman former council until
richard nixon to the justice so all of
that and that but john wilson just a
wonderful lawyer and his partner what
was his name strickler
wow i mean it's one thing that still
works by memory well here it is about
three and a half minutes from 1973 sam
dash asking h.r haldeman about the
president's refusal to give up the tapes
that were
recording all of the oval office
conversations we'll be right back to
take your calls with len garman after
this
this one
last year's question of tapes and then
just a few other questions
uh
they're having questions by some members
of the committee raised yesterday
uh
concerning whether
you employed a a strategy i think
in revealing what you had heard on the
tapes before the committee
and uh
let me let me just make uh
one or two statements in that question
your testimony in it from your testimony
and correct me if i misstate your
testimony
uh your testimony makes it very clear
i believe that you are completely loyal
to the president
and fully support the president's
positions would that be a correct
statement yes sir
uh and i take it you're also aware
that the president has refused to honor
a subpoena issued by this committee
uh for tapes and including specifically
uh these two tapes one the september
15th tape and the march 21st date
i think you're aware of that i am aware
of that yes and that his reason for
doing so has been on executive privilege
and separation of powers reasons
yes
and that at the present time uh the
issue will be going to the courts
i understand that
in mr buzard's letter to you
to your counsel
the mr buzzard states the president had
instructed you
not to reveal the contents of the march
21 tape to the committee
for the same reason on the basis of
executive privilege uh you're aware that
that was in the if you were asked
questions concerning that concerning the
portion
the portion any matters uh
i can't uh quote it but uh the my
understanding of its intent was uh the
prohibition was against testimony
concerning any matters
which i learned solely from listening to
the tape that's what i'm referring to
which would in effect
has given the facts that we're faced
with would in effect uh mean that
portion of the march 21st tape
that uh covered the meeting prior to my
joining it well the question i have
which is
these puzzles made
is that since the
president has uh refused to honor our
subpoena
and the issue of law is to be determined
by the courts
why why did you not follow the
president's example
and refuse to honor the chairman's
order and
obey the president's instructions and
await the court's decision on the law
i'll defer to counsel i acted on advice
of counsel
you want to know what council's advice
was i i take it he acted on the vice
council and i would appreciate hearing
that yes the council's willing to give
it sure
i said if the committee ordered the
the
disclosure of this information
he should obey the order of the
committee
rather than go into contempt
what he said
what would you have said
i would reserve that that answer when i
was counsel for mr holdem and rather
than as chief counselors committee
back live with len garman call for him
from louisville kentucky go ahead good
evening
i have a question uh uh i'm
i'm a naturalized citizen men's role in
that and i think the amount in question
is three hundred fifty thousand dollars
take a look at that and we'll be back to
take your calls
that the dean told you needed money for
this purpose
and you said you could solve that
problem as well as your problem of
getting back to the funds by turning
over the committee
could i put the next two paragraphs in
the record con currently with that uh mr
chairman
do i need to read them or can i just
request that they also
well i'll read them the next paragraph
says to sum up after my original
instruction to strong to transfer the
money to the committee
my involvement in the transfer of funds
was entirely through john dean
he told me of the problem in
transferring the 350 000 to the
committee
he told me he had worked out the problem
he told strong how when and to whom to
make the transfer
he told me the transfer had been made
he did not at any time in this sequence
advise me or imply that the transfer
itself or the purpose of the transfer
was to buy the watergate defendant's
silence or that it was in any way
illegal or improper but he did tell you
that he wanted some money to pay off
the legal fees and found the support
below not that the purpose of the
transfer was but he did yeah i was aware
that that was a and he told you that um
this was to give them a family support
and pay legal fees but was not to buy
their silence
he did not tell me it was not to buy
their silence
well he did not at any time in this
sequence advised me to imply the defense
for itself for the purpose of the
transfer was to buy the watergate
defender's silence so that it was in any
way illegal
that's that's precisely correct mr
chairman b also did not tell me in the
other direction that it was not to buy
sounds the question of buying silence
never arose positively negatively or in
between i asked you if it didn't tell
you
you read that just a moment ago
now the only construction i can put on
that and i don't see your uh well the
only construction i put on the dean came
to you
told you the committee
needed some money to pay
lawyer fees and family support for the
seven watergate defendants
that you told him you had this problem
of which dean was already conscious of
getting the money transferred back to
the committee and you said that he he
could arrange for strong till you get to
accomplish both purposes
that is the purpose of getting the money
is re-transferred to the committee and
the purpose of the committee to get
funds to pay legal and federal fees and
family support for the watergate
defendants
now it took us a long time to get to
that very simple
interpretation now
on the basis of that i would say the
evidence tends to show that
you consider to the use of funds for
of funds forward
payment to the families and the
legal fees
now the evidence in this case shows that
seven men were caught in the i mean
seven men were indicted for breaking and
of burglarizing and bugging the
watergate
including three employees
of the committee
to reelect the president
that these after the rest of these men
they made demands upon the committee to
re-elect the president through the
council of that committee for funds for
their defense and uh
for the support of their families
that they're upon
for a prop about 450 000
derived from funds which had been
contributed for the political
use of of president nixon's committees
called president nixon was paid to these
uh seven the large these seven
men
their lawyers and their families
with the cons with the consent of
officials of the certain officials of
the white house and certain officials of
the committee to re-elect the president
now these are all you you made some
distinction yesterday in uh when you
were interrogated by mr dash
between campaign funds
and some raised in the primary of 1968
now all of these funds
were contributed
by individuals
to advance the political activities and
the political interests of president
nixon
in one way or another
now i would like to ask you
how you can justify
the use of funds contributed to advance
the political interests of president
nixon
either the candidate 1968 or in 1972
with defraying
the uh
defense
and the support of
a seven person charged with burglarizing
or bugging
the democratic national headquarters
i i would not attempt to justify that i
don't know that the funds i don't know
what the source of the funds were or
what the purpose of the funds was well i
thought you said that the funds that uh
many of these funds have been uh raised
by mr comback in connection with the
primary in 1968. i i don't believe they
were i don't know
uh by whom they were raised i i only
know that they were funds that remained
after the 68 campaign that were turned
over to mr convoc's custody for well
that's for use for
the evidence is that all of these funds
were points which had well had been
raised at some time
either for the
they were raised to advance the
political interests of president nixon
and they're not a since hillary elders
that
a single penny album came from any other
source
if you know of in this uh evidence that
it came from any other source be glad to
have it here for now
but my question is how do you i don't
know about the sources of the money
other people have have testified and are
your well supposed
resources for that
everybody's testified including yourself
that all the funds we've been talking
about came from these
donations or contributions everybody
but
but assume there were
can you justify the use of funds
contributed for political purposes to
use
for the
to pay the defense costs
of burglars and buggers
i was not in a position so to justify
this this was this was a decision uh
whatever decision was made
for paying legal fees or reimbursing was
made by people at the uh committee and
people who were in charge of
dealing with this situation
that was not made by me i'll ask you to
review it in hindsight you've given us
your opinion about many things in
hindsight
can you
justify
in the light of the information you have
the use of politically raised funds
to pay to phrase the the defense cost
of
persons charged with burglarizing and
bugging the democratic national
headquarters in the wall gate
on my own i can't make that
justification i don't know what basis
the justification or or reasoning was on
the parts of those who did make that
decision and uh
i have
unfortunate i wasn't born yesterday i've
observed political organizations a long
time
and i have never yet seen a political
organization which was an illegitimate
institution
but assuming that the committees to
reelect the president
or hello masonry institutions
can you tell them tell this committed
why it was when they picked out the
objects of their illuminati concern
that they didn't select anybody
except
seven men
who were accused of complicity in the
burglarizing and bugging the
headquarters of an opposition political
party
mr chairman as i've said i can't
speak to the reasons or or factors in
the decisions that were made by other
people
well
i think you now both
reached the same in capacity to explain
justifiably one of those things so
i will
if my time's not up for our yield back
to balance mitchell the attorney general
of the united states called the white
house horrors which were plans
for further activities such as the
watergate break-in all right it's about
four minutes let's take a look at this
from the summer of 1973 and we'll take
more of your calls
i'd like to submit to you a document
um
uh on white house station memorandum for
mr h.r holloman from ronald h walker
and i think all members of the panel
have a copy and now i submit this copy
to you
excuse me at the same time at the same
time i would like to
submit for your inspection in your
council's inspection
a document dated february 10 1973
memorandum for john dean from h.r holdem
all right now let's discuss
the first
memorandum which i presented to you
administratively confidential the white
house washington october 14 1971 5 pm
memorandum for mr h.r haldeman from
ronald h walker ray charlotte north
carolina demonstrations
one
the most recent intelligence that has
been received from the advanced man bill
henkel in the uss
the united states secret service i got
is that we will have demonstrators in
charlotte tomorrow
the number is running between 100 and
200 the advanced man's gut reaction is
between 150 and 200
they will be violent with a penciled
underlining of violent they will have
extremely obscene signs underlining
obscene
and next to the word obscene
penciled in writing which to me and
you'll have to confirm this it seems to
be the same as the writing below your
initially
appears to be yours if not i want you to
say so saying good
[Music]
is that your writing there where it says
good i believe it is yes sir
um as has been indicated by their hand
bills it will all it will not only be
directed toward the president
but also toward billy graham underlining
underlining also toward billy graham
where you pencil in great
[Music]
mr chairman
i thought the silence was to be enforced
here in this hearing
um mr
wilson i wish you telling science
somewhere i can keep people from
laughing
um i've heard i i don't approve of it
and i wish they'd restrain themselves
and i tried to restrain them
but i don't know i've been told that the
only thing that
distinguishes humanity from what
humanity from a lofty attitude of
disdain
calls to boot creation is the fact that
man laughs and the brute creation does
not
but i'm going to request everybody to
try to restrain their left
and uh
it helps us to proceed in a more orderly
fashion final moments you know i hate to
hear all this about
things like this supposed to happen in
that garden of eden north carolina
and nobody must laugh at that
[Music]
because i we had it
i did um
uh i i would i would also request along
with the chairman uh
the fact that
order is kept uh in this room this is an
extremely serious matter the document
which is now being presented the one to
follow i think probably get to the very
heart of this entire investigation
now the summer of 1973 with us tonight
is carl bernstein who reported for the
washington post and broke the story with
his partner bob woodward after the
break-in at the watergate office in
search of deep throat the greatest
political mystery of our time
then it's the biography of charles
coulson you're watching c-span 3's
writing about history
right now i want to ask you one final
question
now the other day i asked the question
of mr strawn
who worked for you
who was very dedicated in following your
orders
and who expressed great concern
that
right after the
watergate break-in
that he might not have enough
information
and he impressed this committee that he
was almost shaking in his boots because
he did not have enough information to
adequately inform you
at the white house upon your return from
some trip
now i asked him a question which you
know about already and
the question uh revolved around what
advice in view of his experience he
would have for the people for the young
people of this country
with respect to public service
and very dramatically he answered
stay away
i'm trying to elicit from you mr
holderman
you knowing this young man so well
and he having impressed me with his
testimony and his sincerity and his
soldierly dedication to duty
i want you to tell me
from your knowledge of this young man
what might have inspired him
to make such an answer
from his experience and background
well senator montoya let me say that
that
when he gave that answer
i
found it one of the saddest moments of
this hearing because it's an answer that
i
would certainly
give in exactly the opposite direction
and i would have hoped that mr strong
would have answered in exactly the
opposite way from the way that he did
you've asked my opinion
i'm going to ask you what is your advice
to the young people of this country
because
we are in the public service
and
i feel that we should put this matter in
proper context
to me public service
is a trust
public service is an honor
and i'm sure that you can
shed light on this in view of your
previous connection at the white house
as the number one man next to the
president what advice do you have
my advice senator to any young man or
young woman
who feels that he or she has the ability
and the interest
to serve this country in any way
in the government or in any other way
that he should pursue that or she should
that interest
to the fullest of his or her ability
i think it would be tragic
and maybe the greatest of all the many
tragedies that are seem to be
flowing out of this whole situation if
it would result
in any individual
who had decided at some point or who had
been thinking
at some point of coming into the
government to serve
in elective office in a point of office
or as a staff member to a member of
congress or in the white house or any of
the government agencies
if that decision were changed
as a result of of what's going on here
that that would be in my mind an
overriding tragedy i would like to say
that one of the proudest
things that i have in the back of my
mind
is the intention of my oldest son
to enter government service when he
completes his college work which he's in
the middle of now and his intention to
go to law school following that
and i hope to god
that he enters government service in
some way
well i would like to add to that advice
that would be this
that i hope that all young men
who come into the government service
and who have the splendid opportunity
that those men who have appeared before
this committee had
that they will at all times
be alert and careful
and avoid
a watergate pit
would you agree with me on that with all
my heart sir
next c-span threes writing about history
features author leonard garment and his
book in search of deep throat the
greatest political mystery of our time
it's about an hour
unique and telling them our crazy hr bob
holderman about a memo which indicated
abuse of power uh we'll be right back
after uh we hear from senator wyker and
bob haldeman
now this memorandum
for john dean from h.r holloman eyes
only
initial
age obviously the key on the urban
committee is the minority staff and more
importantly the minority council
we've got to be sure we get a real tiger
not an old man or a soft head
and i i can attest to the fact that we
do have a real tiger
and although we let the committee
membership slip out of our grasp
um
we've got to find a way to be sure we
get the very best man we can for council
i've never i haven't concentrated on
that since what what does that mean
and although we let the committee
membership slip out of our grasp what
happened there i don't know
[Music]
also you should go ahead and have
clients order the fbi project on the 68
bugging
so as to gather the data on that and get
the fullest possible information also
mitchell should probably have kendall
called the loach is that don kendall
yes
call can have kendall call deloach in
in and say that if this project turns up
anything that the loach hasn't covered
with us he will of course have to fire
him
what does that i don't i really don't
know what that means at all what do you
what is being referred to there
that's referring to the
1968 bugging
of
mr nixon and mr agnew and apparently
others in the in the campaign or in
connection with that campaign
which took place at a time that mr
deloach was a
i'm not sure of his title but a high
official in the fbi and with which
it was presumed mr loech was
mr deloach was uh familiar
well how do you presume just out of
curiosity to indicate that
if mr deloach
isn't forthcoming that mr kendall should
fire him uh mr kendall isn't employed by
the government is he's is this the
gentleman that is the head of pepsico is
that right that's correct i see it and
uh mr deloach i gather is the employee
of pepsico is that right yes he is now i
see well
how do you issue a memorandum i don't
understand how you issue a memorandum
indicated this if this uh
individual doesn't cooperate mr kendall
should have him fired do you have some
uh hold or did mr mitchell have some
hold over mr kendall
mr mitchell had a uh
personal relationship with mr kendall
and i think mr mitchell
had been in touch with mr kendall or mr
deloach or both
regarding this matter and and had not
gotten
the
information that he was seeking and and
this was a question of
applying additional pressure to to uh
attempt to get the information from mr
deloach that they had nothing
i see in other words uh
we now have the white house reaching
down and uh uh
in the person of you and uh
i i gather
saying to
citizens uh
of this country that if they
if they don't do
what is asked of them
they'll be fired
i don't see any other interpretation on
that is that correct
that's the suggestion that's there
obviously there was no ability on our
part to to uh carry it out
well you took a good swing at the pitch
and i'll say that right now you took a
good swing at the pitch i'll say that
comment well that's i think a pretty
good example of hardball politics
houston texas is next
houston you're on the air
mr dean it's really good to talk to the
country about
watergate
the president's drastic shakeup at the
white house pleased almost every member
of congress for various reasons many
senior republicans have been urging the
president to clean house and he has now
acknowledged that pressure another
reason is that of all the two and a half
million people in the executive branch
by far the most unpopular were h.r
haldeman and john erlickman unpopular
with republicans and democrats alike
paul duke was on the hill when those
resignations were announced
one republican senator said the news was
enough to cause dancing in the halls of
congress the remark illustrated the deep
dislike of haldeman and ehrlichman long
regarded as arrogant and contemptuous
toward members of congress because the
two aides demanded unswerving loyalty to
the president republicans found it
difficult getting to mr nixon if they
deviated even slightly from white house
policy the result was bad feeling and
bad relations for mr nixon thus there
were no tears for messrs haldeman and
ehrlichman i don't think they like
people
i think
i think that
they just give the attitude that uh
they didn't like people my impression of
hollerman very shortly after he was in
there and ehrlichman i think
particularly mr earlier very soon after
he was in there i happened to i'd met
him at receptions i have to run into him
at the airport with his family he's
evidently putting him on a plane for
some place
i went up and spoke to him
well
i never got such a cool off in my life
i'm sure he knew who i was but this is
typical of the uh
of the whole thing i don't really
believe that they
told the president everything
uh
and i assume when they saw themselves
getting in hot water they're even less
inclined to tell the president anything
some thought it would blow away some
thought it would go away
the result was that it didn't the result
beyond that is that it's uh
not a disaster the republican party but
it certainly stained the political
system and all of us involved in it
the attempt to intimidate the members of
the congress is the same as the attempt
to intimidate the members of the press
and great newspapers and television and
radio networks and so forth the media
has been subjected to the same process
that we have the same arrogance they
have been the recipient of
and why this was not apparent before i
do not know but i am very pleased that
the president has now acted as
precipitously
as thoroughly as he now has and i hope
every last person
that was involved in this case will be
dismissed from the federal government
watergate is added to mr nixon's
difficulties on capitol hill but with
holdemon and erlickman gone white house
relations with congress may well improve
once the scandal is over
paul duke nbc news at the capitol
fred briggs went out to a republican
suburb of chicago today a suburb which
has always voted for richard nixon
briggs talked to people trying to find
out how they felt about today's white
house announcement and here is his
report
wilmette is a high income north shore
suburb of chicago it has a long
republican tradition and it held to that
last november by re-electing richard
nixon by a better than two to one margin
over george mcgovern we talked today
with some nixon supporters to see how
they feel now in light of the watergate
revelations
i think it reflects poor judgment on
nixon's part
his um choice of
people surrounding him
i don't think that he has anything to do
with it
i really don't well i don't blame the
president i think he his associates
fooled him quite a bit
well i think it's a shame that it has to
come to this that we have to lose some
good men because of this probing
well i think they're dragging it out too
much i think they should be brought to a
close
well i voted for nixon and unfortunately
i think the whole thing has come up and
his political credibility is just
completely gone i i think now if
he had to be reelected again i'm sure he
wouldn't be almost no matter who ran
against you
if this had all happened uh prior to
last november would it have made any
difference in the way you would have
voted
it might have
this of course was no scientific
sampling but it does suggest there's a
lot of uncertainty among voters who
might have dismissed the watergate
affair as an issue last fall
fred briggs nbc news wilmette illinois
this is nbc nightly news tuesday october
23rd
reported by john chancellor
with david brinkley's journal
good evening on another extraordinary
day
president nixon in a startling reversal
has changed his position on the secret
white house tapes has abandoned his
offer of a compromise summary and will
obey a court order which says he must
give the tapes to judge john cerrika
judge sarika will then privately
determine if the tapes have evidence of
criminal actions the president's
decision came as a total surprise
following a series of significant
developments the president's compromise
arrangement with the senate watergate
committee was coming unstuck
public opinion was swinging against his
position judge sirika this morning was
taking a tough stand in his courtroom
former attorney general elliot
richardson was making a strong defense
of the dismissed special prosecutor
archibald cox and in the house of
representatives for the first time in
more than 100 years an inquiry into
presidential impeachment was begun
it was after these things happened that
the president capitulated here's carl
stern with more on this remarkable day
members of the former special
prosecutor's staff arrived unsure what
role they would play however all the
talking was done by the determined chief
judge john cerrika
sarika indicated as far as he was
concerned the grand jury would still get
what it needed
he called in the grand jurors to tell
them you remain operative it is still
your oath to diligently fully and
completely inquire into all offenses
the former special prosecutors watched
sarika tell the grand jurors they would
not be dismissed until their work was
completed
four hours later the president's lawyers
arrived and announced his capitulation
professor charles allen wright of the
university of texas said the president
would comply in all respects with the
court decisions
judge sarika who read aloud what the
decisions required then asked when the
white house would deliver the tapes
professor wright said it would require
some time but he promised to move
expeditiously he said events had
compelled the president to change his
mind
i've just informed judge sirika
that president nixon will comply in all
respects with the order of this court is
modified by the court of appeals
the
the president on friday
made what he thought attorney general
richardson thought what i thought
was a very reasonable proposal to
accommodate the spirit of the court's
order with the least intrusion of
presidential confidentiality
and bring a constitutional crisis to an
end
it was obvious that the constitutional
crisis was not over
that even if as i hope he would have
judge sirica had accepted
the presentation that we had planned to
make
as satisfactory compliance there would
have been those who would have said that
the president is defying the law
this president does not defy the law
the sudden turn of events surprised even
the court yesterday the white house sent
a response to the judge outlining the
president's original position but this
afternoon professor wright asked that it
be considered withdrawn the lawyer's way
of declaring it inoperative
oh
let me ask you some questions has the
president brought himself some time by
his actions today
i think it's fair to say that what the
president has done is to
withdraw to live to fight another day at
least politically do you think that the
presentation of these nine secret tapes
will go smoothly now that this has been
arranged
the court of appeals decision still
permits the president to withhold
portions of the tapes that pertain to
national defense or foreign relations
and for the most part the court will
have to assume that he's doing so
honestly his lawyers can also fight to
keep out other matters considered
irrelevant or prejudicial or which are
not yet under subpoena so there's plenty
of room there for the white house to
maneuver
carl some people are saying that by
firing cox the president has set up a
situation where the defendant who is the
president has been able to fire the
prosecutor now that cox is gone do you
think the justice department will pursue
this investigation as vigorously as cox
the outlook of the justice department is
brighter than it seems acting attorney
general robert bork called in some of
archibald cox's former staff members
yesterday to keep them on the case and
don't forget that assistant attorney
general henry peterson wants to
vindicate his operation this time and so
he really has the president hostage
the president can't afford to have
peterson quit now complaining that the
white house is blocking the
investigation
carl thank you
at the white house this afternoon there
was a press briefing on the events of
this day tom brokaw has that story
general alexander haig the president's
chief aide and professor charles allen
wright the chief white house lawyer in
this situation
explained mr nixon's position
hague said he didn't believe the
president would be impeached if even if
he did not give up the tapes
but when it was all stripped away it
came down to this
the president was forced to change his
mind by the political events that were
closing in on him
that was not the attitude at the white
house last friday however when the
stennis compromise was first announced
i checked out of the madison saturday
morning thinking i was done with white
house employment forever that the
american people would give a tremendous
sigh of relief
at the thought that now we are going to
hear what is in these tapes
and now we are not going to have a
constitutional crisis
obviously that was a miscalculation
saturday morning it still looked like a
very good calculation
what we had miscalculated was
that they did not we had not thought
that mr cox
would take the course of action that he
did
that led to further traumatic events
as a result by this morning
it was apparent that rather than a
national sigh of relief in the end of a
constitutional crisis
that the crisis was simply heightened
although neither right nor cox would
express it apparently the white house
expected archibald cox to quit last
weekend and not to fight as for the
senate watergate committee the
compromise of last week now is off the
committee will not get the summaries of
the president's tapes but already that
committee is moving in the courts once
again in an attempt to get those tapes
through legal channels
haig would not address himself to the
question of whether another special
prosecutor would be appointed but he did
say that during all of this there was
white house concern about the political
alignment as he expressed it
of the staff that was working with
archibald cox clearly suggesting that
that staff might have been out to get
president nixon for political reasons
while hague and professor wright were
meeting with with reporters today here
at the white house president nixon was
on route to camp david apparently to
prepare that national speech that he
will give tomorrow night tom brokaw nbc
news at the white house
our history shows the american people
will put up with a great deal even when
the demands on them are outrageous as
they often are
but they will not put up with anyone who
claims to be or tries to be above the
law immune to the rules applying to
everybody else
it seems to be known instinctively that
if anyone acquires that privilege it'll
be the end of this country
the public will not obey laws they
dislike if their leaders don't
it appears the white house feeling
threatened has long since pulled its
wagons into a circle and lost touch with
what was happening outside
there is every evidence they were
surprised by the degree of public anger
at the events of last weekend
so the president backed down said he'd
hand over the tapes whereas in the past
he argued this was an intolerable
invasion of his privacy
well other people's privacy is routinely
invaded by the federal government and
anyone else who tried to withhold
evidence that might bear on a crime
would wind up in jail
it has always seemed doubtful that
congress could actually bring itself to
impeach the president but since saturday
night it has seemed they might actually
face up to it
so the president backed down
because he had to
john
and good night for nbc news
we're back in 1997 with john fialka who
covered the watergate story for the
washington star as